people wake up in the morning
they
begin to think about their problems
those problems are circuits of memories
in the brain each one of those memories
are connected to people and things at
certain times and places and if the
brain is a record of the past
the moment they start their day they're
already thinking in the past each one of
those memories has an emotion
emotions are the end product of past
experiences
so the moment they recall those memories
of their problems they all of a sudden
feel unhappy they feel sad they feel
pain
now how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being so the
person's entire state of being when they
start their day is in the past so what
does that mean the familiar past will
sooner or later be predictable future
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
or feelings have become the means of
thinking by very definition of emotions
you're thinking in the past and for the
most part you're going to keep creating
the same life so then people grab their
cell phone
they check their what's up they check
their text they check their emails they
check facebook they take a picture of
their feet they post it on facebook they
tweet something they do instagram
they check the news and now they feel
really connected to everything that's
known in their life and then they go
through a series of routine behaviors
they get out of bed on the same side
they go to the toilet they get a cup of
coffee they take a shower they get
dressed they drive to work the same way
they do the same things they see the
same people that push the same emotional
buttons and that becomes
the routine and it becomes like a
program
so now they've lost their free will
to a program and there's no unseen hand
doing it to them so when it comes time
to change the redundancy of that cycle
becomes a subconscious program so now 95
of who we are by the time we're 35 years
old
is a memorized set of behaviors
emotional reactions unconscious habits
hardwired attitudes beliefs and
perceptions
that function like a computer program
so then person can say with their five
percent of their conscious mind
i want to be healthy i want to be happy
i want to be free
but the bodies on a whole different
program so then how do you begin to make
those changes well you have to get
beyond the analytical mind because what
separates the conscious mind from the
subconscious mind is the analytical mind
and that's where meditation comes in
because you can teach people
through practice how to change their
brain wave slow them down and when they
do that properly they do enter the
operating system where they can begin to
make some really important changes
so
most people then wait for crisis or
trauma or disease or diagnosis you know
they wait for loss
uh some tragedy to make up their mind to
change and my message is why wait and
and you can learn and change in a state
of pain and suffering or you can learn
and change in a state of joy and
inspiration i think right now the cool
thing is that people are waking up if
you're not being defined by a vision of
the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life and if you wake up in the
morning and you're not being defined by
a vision in the future as you see the
same people and you go to the same
places and you do the exact same thing
at the exact same time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
network in your brain
every experience that you have with
every person produces an emotion so some
people will use their boss to reaffirm
their addiction to judgment they'll use
their enemy to reaffirm their addiction
to hatred they'll use their friends to
reaffirm their addiction to suffering so
now they need the outer world to feel
something
so
to change then
is to be greater than your environment
to be greater than the conditions in
your world and the environment is that
seductive
so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's close our eyes
let's disconnect
from your outer environment so if you're
seeing less things there's less
stimulation going to your brain if
you're playing soft music or you have
ear plugs in less sensory information
coming to your brain so you're
disconnecting from your environment if
you can sit your body down and tell it
to stay like an animal stay right here
i'm gonna feed you and we're done you
can get up and check your emails you can
do all your texts but right now you're
to sit there and obey me
so then
when you do that properly and you're not
eating anything or smelling anything or
tasting anything you're not up
experiencing and feeling anything
you would have to agree with me that
you're being defined by a thought right
so when the body wants to go back to its
emotional past and you become aware that
your attention is on that emotion and
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy you're siphoning
your energy out of the present moment
into the past and you become aware of
that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's 8 o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling anger and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions
and you settle it back down into the
present moment you're telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will
is getting greater than the program and
if you keep doing this over and over
again over and over again over and over
again just like training a stallion or a
dog it's just gonna say
i'm gonna sit and the moment that
happens the body is no longer the mind
when it finally surrenders
your body is your unconscious mind
in a sense if you're sitting down and
you start thinking about
some future worst case scenario that
you're conjuring up in your mind
and you begin to feel the emotion of
that event
your body doesn't know the difference
between the event that's taking place in
your world our world and what you're
creating by emotion or thought alone
so most people then
they're they're constantly reaffirming
their emotional states so when it comes
time to give up that emotion
they can say i really want to do it but
really the body is stronger than the
mind because it's been conditioned that
way so
the servant now has become the master
and the person all of a sudden
once they step into that unknown they'd
rather feel guilt in suffering because
at least they can predict it being the
unknown
is a scary place for most people because
the unknown is uncertain people say to
me well i can't predict my future i'm in
the unknown and i always say the best
way to predict your future is to create
it not from the known but from the
unknown what thoughts do you want to
fire and wire in your brain
what behaviors do you want to
demonstrate in one day
the act of rehearsing them mentally
closing your eyes and rehearsing the
action
they're rehearsing the reaction of what
you want or
the action of what you want by closing
your eyes and mentally rehearsing some
action
if you're truly present the brain does
not know the difference between what
you're imaging and what you're
experiencing in 3d world so then you
begin to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to look like the
event has already occurred now your
brain is no longer a record of the past
now it's a map to the future and if you
keep doing it priming it that way
the hardware becomes a software program
and who knows you just may start acting
like a happy person and then i think the
hardest part is to teach our body
emotionally what the future will feel
like ahead of the actual experience so
what does that mean you can't wait for
your success to feel empowered you can't
wait for your wealth to feel abundant
you can't wait for your your new
relationship to feel love or
your healing to feel whole i mean that's
the old model of reality of cause and
effect you know waiting for something
outside of us to change how we feel
inside of us and when we feel better
inside of us we pay attention to whoever
whatever caused it what that means then
is that from the newtonian worlds that
most people spend their whole life
living in lack the newtonian world is
all about the predictable it's all about
predicting the future but the quantum
model of reality is is about causing an
effect the moment you start feeling
abundant and worthy you are generating
wealth the moment you're empowered and
feel it you're beginning to step towards
your success
the moment you start feeling whole your
healing begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal and now you're causing
an effect i think that's the the
difference between living as a victim
in your world saying i am this way
because of this person or that thing or
this experience they made me think and
feel this way when you switch that
around you become a creator of your
world and you start saying my thinking
and my feeling is changing an outcome in
my life and now that's a whole different
game and we start believing more that
we're creators of reality
and so
when you have an emotional reaction to
someone or something most people think
that they can't control their emotional
reaction well it turns out if you allow
that emotional reaction it's called a
refractory period to last for hours or
days and if you keep that same emotional
reaction going on for years on end
that's called a personality trait and so
learning how to shorten your refractory
period of emotional reactions is really
where the work starts so then people
when they have an event what they do is
they keep recalling the event because
the emotions of stress hormones their
survival emotions are saying pay
attention to what happened because you
want to be prepared if it happens again
turns out most people spend 70 percent
of their life living in survival and
living in stress so they're they're
always anticipating
the worst case scenario based on a past
experience and they're literally
out of the infinite potentials in the
quantum field they're selecting the
worst possible outcome and they're
beginning to emotionally embrace it with
fear and they're conditioning their body
into a state of fear do that enough
times
body has a panic attack without you you
can't even predict it because it's
programmed subconsciously so then the
emotions from the experience tend to
give the body and the brain a rush of
energy
so people become addicted to the rush of
those emotions and they use the problems
and conditions in their life to reaffirm
their limitation so at least they can
feel something so now when it comes time
to change you say the person why are you
this way well every time they recall the
event they're producing the same
chemistry in their brain and body as if
the event is occurring
firing and wiring the same circuits and
sending the same emotional signature to
the body what's the relevance behind
that well your body is the unconscious
mind it doesn't know the difference
between the experience that's creating
the emotion and the emotion that you're
creating by thought alone so the body's
believing it's living in the same past
experience and so then when those
emotions influence certain thoughts and
they do and then those thoughts create
the same emotions and those same
emotions influence the same thoughts now
the entire person's state of being is in
the past while the redundancy of that
cycle conditions the body to become the
mind so now when it comes time to change
a person steps into that river of change
and they make a different choice and all
of a sudden they don't feel the same way
so the body says well you've been doing
this for 35 years you're going to just
stop feel suffering and stop feeling
guilty and stop feeling shameful and
you're not going to complain or blame or
make excuses or feel sorry for yourself
well
the body's in the unknown so the body
says i want to return back to familiar
territory so the body starts influencing
the mind and it says start tomorrow
you're too much like your mother you'll
never change this isn't going to work
for you this doesn't feel right
and so if you respond to that thought
your life's not going to change very
much because the same thought leads to
the same choice the same choice leads to
the same behavior the same behavior
creates the same experience and the same
experience produces the same emotion and
most people when they have a thought
they just think that that's the truth
and i think one of my greatest
realizations in my own journey was
just because you have a thought doesn't
necessarily mean it's true so if you
think 60 to 70 000 thoughts in one day
and we do and 90 of those thoughts are
the same thoughts as the day before and
you believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny and so
then the act of becoming conscious of
this process to to begin to become more
aware of how you think how you act and
how you feel it's called metacognition
and so then why is that important
because the more conscious
you become of those unconscious states
of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought is not going to slip by your
awareness unchecked because it means to
know thyself the word meditation means
to become familiar with so as you become
familiar with the thoughts the behaviors
and the emotions of the old self you're
retiring that old self as you fire and
wire new thoughts and condition the body
into a new emotional state if you do
that enough times it'll begin to become
familiar to you so it's so important uh
just like a garden if you're planting a
garden you got to get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you've got to pull them out the
rocks that sift to the top that are like
our emotional blocks they have to be
removed soil has to be tenderized and
broken down we have to make room to
plant a new garden so primarily we learn
the most about ourselves and others when
we're uncomfortable because the moment
you move into that uncomfortable state
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps in it's because a person
doesn't want to be in the present moment
and engage it consciously so when you
teach people how to do that
with a meditative process turns out that
when they're in their life
they're less likely to emotionally react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change
and so we have to unlearn before we
relearn we have to break the habit of
the old self before we reinvent the new
self we have to prune synaptic
connections and sprout new connections
we have to unfire and unwire and re-fire
and rewire we have to unmemorize
emotions that are stored in the body
then recondition the body to a new mind
into a new motion like deprogram and
reprogram that's the act and it's a
two-step process
[Music]
you